AND THE MEETING HAPPENING BEHIND
US.
>> Bret: FOLKS WALKING IN.
WE WILL LET YOU DO SOME WORK AND
GET AN UPDATE LATER ON.
THE SEARCH FOR THE SUSPECT IN
THE SHOOTING AT A TENNESSEE
WAFFLE HOUSE IS OVER.
POLICE ARRESTED TRAVIS REINKING
NOT FAR FROM HIS APARTMENT A FEW
HOURS AGO.
CORRESPONDENT JONATHAN SERRIE
JOINS US LIVE FROM ANTIOCH WITH
MORE.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING.
UNTIL THIS AFTERNOON, POLICE SAY
THEY HAD RECEIVED NO CREDIBLE
SIGHTINGS OF THE SUSPECT.
BUT THEY CONTINUE TO FOCUS THEIR
SEARCH AREA HERE IN ANTIOCH,
TENNESSEE, VERY CLOSE TO THE
SCENE OF THE CRIME, THE WAFFLE
HOUSE YOU SEE BEHIND ME.
VIDEO FROM AN EYEWITNESS
SMARTPHONE SHOWS THE SUSPECT
TRAVIS REINKING IN POLICE
CUSTODY MINUTES AFTER HIS ARREST
IN A WOODED AREA NEAR THIS
APARTMENT COMPLEX NOT FAR FROM
THE WALL FLOSS OR A MASS
SHOOTING CLAIMED THE LIVES OF
FOUR PEOPLE EARLY SUNDAY MORNING
AND THE NATIONAL SUBURB --
NATIONAL SUBURB OF ANTIOCH.
>> WE REALIZED IT'S THE SUSPECT
WE WERE LOOKING FOR.
DETECTIVES DREW DOWN ON THE
SUSPECT.
HE GOT ON THE GROUND.
HE PRUNED HIMSELF OUT.
>> PRIOR TO SUNDAY'S SHOOTING,
REINKING WAS NO STRANGER TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IN ILLINOIS, THIS 2016 POLICE
REPORT EXPLAINED TRAVIS REINKING
WAS DELUSIONAL AND BELIEVE THE
FAMOUS ENTERTAINER TAYLOR SWIFT
WAS HARASSING HIM VIA STOCKING
AND HACKING HIS PHONE.
THE FOLLOWING YEAR THE
SECRET SERVICE ARRESTED HIM FOR
REFUSING TO LEAVE A RESTRICTED
AREA NEAR THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT PROMPTED AUTHORITIES TO SEIZE
REINKING'S GUNS AND PLACE THEM
IN HIS FATHER'S CUSTODY BUT THE
FATHER EVENTUALLY RETURNED
WEAPONS TO A SON, INCLUDING THE
AR-15 USED AT THE WAFFLE HOUSE.
>> IS POSSIBLE IF YOU TRANSFER
WEAPONS IT'S PROHIBITED.
COULD POTENTIALLY BE A VIOLATION
OF FEDERAL LAW.
>> THREE PEOPLE DIED AT THE
SCENE ON THE FOURTH AT A
HOSPITAL.
POLICE SAY COULD'VE BEEN WORSE
IF IT HADN'T BEEN FOR THE QUICK
ACTION OF A CUSTOMER WHO DECIDED
TO RUSH THE GUNMAN AS HE
APPEARED TO BE RELOADING OR
UNJAMMING HIS WEAPON.
>> I MANAGED TO GET, ONE HAND ON
THE GUN AND I GRABBED IT FROM
HIM AND I THREW IT OVER THE
COUNTERTOP.
>> AFTER HIS ARREST, REINKING
IMMEDIATELY REQUESTED AN
ATTORNEY HAD MADE NO STATEMENTS
TO POLICE.